a suburb classified by Danish
authorities as a hard ghetto the term
refers to areas where crime poverty and
unemployment rates are high
deeper now risk being evicted and their
houses demolished after a law that was
introduced in 2018 to get rid of all
so-called ghettos by 2030.
last April the boy Parkin was the first
residential building to be knocked down
Ibrahim al-hassan is determined to fight
the law his childhood home is slated
next for demolition it's very sad this
is the area I grew up in this is like my
entire childhood was here in the area so
seeing it in front of me just being torn
apart being demolished
it's very sad
people in vosmosi have invited the main
political parties for a town hall debate
but it might be too late
the Danish government says these
so-called gutters stand for everything
that went wrong with past immigration
policies and failed integration but for
the people who live in areas like the
Bowie Parkin that once stood here the
new law is just an excuse to impose more
discriminatory measures against Muslim
immigrants far-right and Centrist
candidates are all calling for stricter
anti-immigration laws ahead of the
general election on November the 1st we
really can't save the whole world by
saying yes we open the doors it's free
to come we have to have kind of barrier
because otherwise we can't keep up with
the health system which also needs to be
scaled up if you had more people in in
the country 12 neighborhoods fall into
the ghetto category anxious families
have to cope with relocating and finding
new schools for their children
the atmosphere is becoming so much tense
that you want some kind of guarantee
even the you know the social Democrats
haven't been living up to what they have
been promising so people are you know
unsure about where to to vote the
initial Authority is worn low-income
immigrant neighborhoods have become
parallel societies threatening Denmark's
way of life to protect that generous
welfare state they say they want to shut
the door to immigrants and refugees
Southwest of Copenhagen